[Music]  [Music]  the more people who leave the donetsk  region now the fewer people the russian  army will have time to kill  [Music]  my son was there i don't know how he is  where he is if he is alive or not i  don't know it's a horror for a mother  it's the biggest loss if her child has  gone  [Music]  so i think right now we're seeing a very  interesting part of this conflict  wherein ukrainian forces might be in a  position to actually retake territory  that they lost in the south and i think  the russians are worried about that and  the russians have a difficult  operational decision ahead of them how  much do they pull from the east where  they're really trying to make more  progress to you know reinforce the south  so they don't lose territory and you  know donbass i think still remains the  russian priority whereas the south  remains ukraine's priority so both sides  have have rather challenging operational  decisions to make as to where they  deploy their forces  [Music]